clap de fin pour anglet la merkel la
chancelière allemande s'apprête à
quitter le pouvoir après 16 ans de règne
pendant ses quatre mandats elle en
oeuvre un passé des présidents français
quatre au total de jacques chirac à
emmanuel macron avec des hauts et
parfois des barques vive l'amitié franco
amant novembre 2005 angela merkel
devient chancelière allemande son
premier voyage à l'étranger elle leur
réserve pour jacques chirac à paris ce
qui attire l'attention c'est le fameux
baise main du président français la
relation est amicale jusqu'au départ du
locataire de l'elysée en 2007
je voudrais simplement te dire du fond
du coeur
toute mon estime toute ma reconnaissance
et toute mon affection 2007 merkel
sarkozy les deux dirigeants se
connaissent déjà regards complices
embrassades petite blague c'est la
naissance du couple mercredi la presse
parle beaucoup de notre couple je
félicite monsieur merkel qui est là
je voudrais lui dire de ne pas croire
tout ce qui est écrit dans la presse en
2008 en pleine crise économique le
couple bat de l aile mais à chaque fois
l'amitié franco-allemande eux reprend le
dessus du moins en façade ici nous
sommes en 2009 lors des commémorations
de l'armistice à paris vive la france
vive
allemagne vive l'amitié franco allemande
2012 nouveau tandem merkel hollande pour
son premier déplacement le président
français décolle pour berlin son avion
prend la foudre sur le tapis rouge et
sous la pluie sa démarche est hésitante
à la tribune la chancelière allemande
préfère en rire nous sommes d'autant
plus heureux d'accueillir françois
hollande que la foudre a frappé son
avion et on peut y voir un heureux
présage sur la coopération entre nous
entre les deux ce n'est pas l'amour fou
mais en janvier 2015 angela merkel
laisse de côté les tensions elle vient
soutenir françois hollande après les
attentats de charlie hebdo même chose en
novembre après les attaques terroristes
à paris ces attaques ne s'adressait pas
seulement à paris c'était des attaques
contre notre mode de vie contre les
démocraties
et contre l'europe 2017 emmanuel macron
est élu et angela merkel est toujours là
au début il n'y a pas d'osmose comme
avec nicolas sarkozy mais en mai 2020 la
crise du colis de 10,9 à les réconcilier
je pense que l'allemagne et la france
ont fourni une bonne base d'accord mais
il est clair que nous nous dirigeons
vers des négociations difficiles
angela merkel a été la première femme à
être désignée chancelière allemande
après 16 ans au pouvoir elle égale le
record de longévité d'helmut kohl son
ancien parrain en politique
[Musique]